[Music]
do
good morning my name's scott johnson
from the low technology institute and
this is part one of a two-part series on
home scale grain production and today i
need to prepare the soil and plant oats
and barley as you can see we've got a
field here that was more or less fallow
last year so we need to
at least knock down this weed load and
then plant seeds in it i have tried
no-till
i haven't had good luck with it the
weeds seem to out-compete
the the grains i tried to grow so what i
do is basically disk the top i use a
tiller with going in just an inch or two
knocking all this vegetation down
planting the seeds in and the seeds then
have a good a good head start and are
able to
over top the weeds
so i don't have to use a lot of
herbicides or
anything like that
i am going to fertilize a little bit in
this field using horse manure if i'm
growing other things i don't i'll talk
about each plant a little bit as we go
but for now
let's get let's get tilling
[Music]
let's talk real briefly about fertilizer
generally speaking uh different
types of grain and different types of
applications need different amounts of
fertilizer
for example rye grows really well with
almost no fertilizer so i'm growing rye
where i grew corn last year without a
problem
wheat for me i don't fertilize and i
grow on a little bit of a
restricted diet so to speak because i
want really good woody growth for the
stems because i use it for thatch
you could fertilize a bit more and maybe
get a little more yearly i'm not that i
don't care that much about that
because this was used for wheat last
year i'm actually going to put some
horse manure on it some well-rotted
composted harvest manure i've already
tilled it once i'll spread out the horse
manure and then i'll till it again and
then i'll be ready for seeding
i'm going to do the same for my barley
and
i'm also going to be tilling and putting
in field peas which are soup peas or a
dried pea that you can then cook into
soup because they are a legume they fix
nitrogen in the soil so i actually don't
have to fertilize them at all
and they're not really a grain but i'm
talking about them because this is the
time that i would plant them
this is spring and you might say
spring is
too late for a wheat and you're right
winter wheat is planted in the fall as
is rye depends where you live it's
different time so you'll want to check
with your local extension or your local
state agencies for that timing
but you definitely want to get it in at
least like a month before the first
frost so that it has a good time to
start growing it's frost hearty but it's
nice to get a little bit of time
oats
barley spring wheat get planted in the
spring
and so right now this will be oats and
so i'm telling this up uh in the spring
we're still getting frosts but that's
not a big deal or a hindrance
i could have tilled this up in the fall
and applied my fertilizer that probably
would have been preferable and then
maybe i would have given little light
disking to take down any weeds that had
started
now when it comes to seeding there's a
couple different options um
you can broadcast seed broadcast seeding
is the traditional way
um and what one can do is take a sack or
an apron
and have
their seed in and what you do
your seeding rate is
driven by your foot steps so
for some seating rates you would take a
step
and throw
and then one and step and throw
and one and step and throw
if you want a denser seating rate then
you could throw throw
throw throw on each step
or even every third step whatever
i don't know
what a seeding rate would be you would
have to experiment on your own to figure
that out
what i do for laying down my seed is i
put down rows
and because i do not have a large
mechanical cedar i have to use a single
row cedar
a garden an earthway cedar
if you have a multiple
cedar good for you i don't and so what i
do is i make eight inch rows and so i've
got a measuring tape down here and i'm
putting down these white
poles every eight inches and then i'm
going to run the cedar between them
and when i look down the
the field i see the rest of them
i see this exact same setup on the other
side and so what's going to happen is i
will just take the cedar and run
straight down to its partner
and that will give me a nice row the
reason being
rows let me weed a little better because
i can differentiate between
what is seeded for
for grain and what is weeds
this is especially important
if you're coming off of grass there was
grass here before and so this is
something i'm gonna have to fight with
i find that to be my best
um
spacing
you can experiment and find what works
best for you
now as far as seeding rate goes i'll
talk about that when i get my cedar out
here in a minute
okay let's talk cedars i don't have a
big cedar uh like that goes behind a
tractor and has 20
60 drills i have this walk behind garden
seeder which
is not designed for grain so i have to
modify it slightly
and uh this seeder basically what
happens is it turns
uh this wheel as you walk this disc in
here turns and pulls up seeds and dumps
them out down the chute into this drill
that's uh plowing its way through the
soil
and as we'll see in the video coming up
but
i need to drop about 10 seeds for each
foot
one revolution of this
of this wheel is three feet
so basically i need to find
one of these
discs that's gonna pick up and drop 30
wheat kernels
for over three feet over one rotation of
this
and so basically what i do
to figure this out and i already know
the answer but um
i'm going to do this so you can find for
whatever grain you're planting and
whatever seeding rate you want
so
i'm first going to start with the beats
okra chard
disc
this slots right in
now i'm going to open up my
these are
streaker or hulless oats
i'm doing hull this out so i don't have
to
take the hull off which i don't have
equipment for
we'll talk about that in video number
two
[Applause]
so here we have our oats
i'm just gonna drop
a handful in here
[Applause]
okay
now
now what i do
is i set this over a bowl
and
once it starts dropping i rotate one
full rotation so
okay so there we go so from the top
so that would represent
three feet of walking
[Music]
[Applause]
now i take the oats out
and i count them
approximately
78. that's more than twice as much of
what i need almost three times what i
need um and so one option i would have
and i dump all these seeds out
one option i would have to modify this
would be to take tape and go right over
every other one of these and you push it
down right nice and tight and then tear
it off so it's not on the back otherwise
it gums up the system i would cut that
clean
and that would reduce my seeding rate by
half and i would do that here here
uh here and here and then right that
would reduce the seeding rate and it
would spread them out a little bit
that's one option or i can try another
one so this is um
cabbage onions endive turnips
discs you can also buy blank discs and
then use a heated
metal probe to create your own
dishes little little dish cups to catch
this and maybe someday i will do that
since i do do a lot of grain
make my life a little easier all right
let's see how many this does
[Music]
foot
it's doing almost none
i can see them dropping in there it's
almost none because this disc is too
small
so that doesn't work
right so it's basically trial and error
so let's talk seeding rates
when you look on an agricultural
extension or
some website about growing wheat it's
going to tell you how much seed they put
in the big machines they sew at
something like
80 to 120 pounds per acre
i'm not doing acres how many pounds
right so i don't use that what i use is
um per square foot how many seeds or
because i do eight inch spacing of all
of my rows um i just do it by how many
seeds per foot i know for wheat i like
about 10
seeds
purse per linear foot on eight inch
spacing that gives me like 14
seeds per
per square foot and what that does is
it's like
a quarter or a half of the recommended
tilling rate uh seeding rate for
industrial wheat because what i want is
tillering so usually an industrial wheat
you have one seed you have one plant
well tillering that one plant senses
that has space around it so it sends up
multiple plants so from one seed i get
multiple heads it's more seeds i get
more return on the seeds i invest
and also it works well
in my application i'm not sewing as
densely i'm not fertilizing so it's nice
to have that one larger stronger plant
rather than a whole bunch of small
plants
so right now i'm seeing oats
i could still till at a similar rate but
i think i'm actually going to over seed
because i have a little more oat seed
than i do space so i might actually just
use this one
another another modification you can do
is take a piece of tape and go right
here so the cup is still open but it's
reduced and if i do that that will
somewhat reduce
the seeding rate and i'll have to test
it to figure out what that is but play
with tape and play with your seeding
discs and you can usually find something
that is close to the seeding rate you
want and if you don't know what your
seeding rate should be do that's what i
did my first year i grew some at the
industrial seeding rate at the suggested
rate i did some at half that i did some
at a quarter of that and i did some at
double that
and what worked best for me was half the
industrial rate so i just did it by
experimentation i highly recommend
that approach
when we're dealing with small scale
because the people who knew how to do
small scale wheat growing are either
dead or there's actually a lot of people
around the world who still grow
wheat this way but they probably
broadcast i don't know how many small
scale farmers in less developed parts of
the world actually use a cedar i imagine
most of them just use a
broadcast method which is a little
easier
now i'm going to do is line up with my
cedar in this first space and walk
down
uh to its partner down at the far end
and then and when i'm walking i focus
far away from me i focus on the far end
of the field and that lets me
keep a straight line i'm planting these
at a depth of about
three quarters of an inch to an inch if
you notice as i walk i drag
the forward
in this case my right foot
and and deposit a little soil over the
line that i've just sewn that helps bury
the
grain a little bit so the birds don't
get it all
and then when i finish a route
i take out the
post
so that it's easy for me to see
that i'm just headed for the next one
that's available
and i don't mind trampling
the ground
because that would be done often after
seeding in like ancient egypt they would
run their sheep or cows over to trample
the
soil in that's no problem
after each pass i refill
and here you can see the result of this
type of seeding here's last year's
rye and here's last year's wheat you can
see there is some uh
some competing weeds coming up here but
because these are spaced at eight inch
intervals i can walk my high wheel hoe
down them and knock all this down once
and then this is gonna grow up to be
this high it'll blot out all other weeds
and this was prepared just the same way
i planted the oats so you can see the
nice the nice results this this has
well thanks so much for watching part
one part two we'll cover harvesting and
threshing i think we're actually gonna
do a part three on grinding because that
deserves its own episode that won't come
out till later this summer so if you
want to be sure to see it hit the
subscribe button below
if you want to do a little more hands-on
if you'd like some hands-on experience
doing this we will offer classes this
summer on harvesting and processing your
own wheat so check out our website
lowtechinstitute.org
events and you can see when those
classes come up you can also sign up to
our listserv to make sure that you
are alerted when we have new classes up
we'd love to put these things out for
free and we're going to continue to do
that but it does take time and resources
from our staff to put them together so
if you're in a position to join the
community of people supporting us please
consider going over to patreon.com low
tech institute
to find out more we have membership
starting at as low as three dollars a
month
and not only does that help us out
financially but also psychologically to
have have folks helping us out so if
you're in a position please do consider
supporting us we really appreciate it um
and we're already looking forward to
parts two and three of this video so
thanks for watching and take care of
yourselves
[Music]
you